oh my goodness
okay so i came across a comment on one
of our videos if we're 90s kids you
might want to check out the latest
mortal kombat video i was like what i'm
sure i would have gotten my notification
bell did not show up in my notification
bells
i'm so annoyed by that mortal kombat 11
official classic mk movie skins reveal
trailer saw twice the first movie i saw
twice in the theater's
opening day theater hop baby before
there was reserve seating
when there was theaters
johnny k sonja raiden no way
[Music]
like this remix
what all mortal kombat fans have been
craving more christopher lambert
[Music]
scorpion yes
oh are they going to get lou kang in
there do you get robin chow oh
mortal kombat annihilation and get the
weird dragon thing to come out
oh they gotta get and i don't want the
world to come out future characters from
james
one's mortal kombat movie in there we'll
just get every movie
it's so funny because this morning i was
thinking a lot about uh the
the the web series the mortal kombat
legacy one and my mind was just
really going there for some reason and
going man i can't wait for that new
mortal kombat movie to come out i think
about a month ago i went down the
wormhole of zergnet.com where i was
learning about bridget wilson and like
where the hell has she been lately and i
forgot
everything about her well she got me
married or something and gave up acting
i i think that's what happened she had a
family and she gave it but either way
i mean seeing them brought to life here
i want them to do every character from
there they already got shang sung in
there obviously yeah if you can get like
i don't know if they've done robin shout
yet but the fact that they got
christopher lambert here they got
bridget wilson whoever played johnny
cage
that's exciting to me that's really
exciting to me yeah totally i mean they
should just make like some
a movie yeah they should build on this
with a movie pack have some movie skins
of like here are some classic
sets yeah you know here are the classic
costumes from the beloved motion picture
and they gotta bring some more
characters in right especially with the
waves of 90s nostalgia that are
continually true in the cultural did you
see the mortal kombat movie i did
oh my god i didn't see it in the
theaters like you i wasn't cool
seen something i've seen something
recovering on this show oh my god
participated in something oh yes yes
this is the most important video we've
done fighter all week in
both of those movies all right guys well
this is great i'm so sorry to not
shout out whoever mentioned in the
comments but it was on the try not to
laugh for family guy thank you
for the one who mentioned that at three
o'clock p.m
anywho subscribe click that notification
bell damn youtube notifications for not
letting me know when this came out hours
ago
either way happy to catch it